hey what's going on hot ones fans Sean
Evans checking in and in case you missed
it Kevin Durant hosted a live event at
YouTube space in LA last week we made
the rounds with youtubers like ryan
toysreview and what's inside regrettably
I'm sure he also chose to invite hot
ones the set ups a little bit different
this time around and since Kevin didn't
get to do a plug I'm gonna do it for him
now
check out Kevin Durant on YouTube lots
of cool beats yes stuff plus he's doing
it his own way and we respect the hell
out of that around these parts well
without further ado here's Kevin Durant
versus the wings of death
all right Katie nice to meet you my man
so we're here at YouTube space in LA
you've gone through what's inside you've
gone through Ryan's toy review but now
we're really cranking up the heat here
with the wings of jasmine yeah
how are you with hot food are you a
spicy food guy you just say that yeah
well we'll find out if you are really
right into the hot ones fans man needs
no introduction MVP eight-time all-star
NBA champion but can t handle Blair's
Megadeth sauce with liquid rage we'll
find out today Kevin ready get going yes
sir
[Music]
[Music]
before we start I don't want to put too
much pressure on you but Kevin Love came
in here and he cleared the board got on
top of the wings no added pressure just
want to just won't put that out there
just want to put that in your head we're
doing yeah so there are a lot of
milestones to chase when you're an NBA
player the trophies the banners the
rings but I think the most underrated
thing is the hip-hop shout out oh yeah
yeah when you think about all the times
that you've been named checked in rap
lyrics which one's your favorite oh
that's a great question Jake : me out on
this last album which went double
platinum that was pretty cool
Drake did on his last album busting drug
flow yeah yeah a lot of my friends loved
that one so now you listening to these
guys and they pull your name out there
it makes you feel pretty established I'm
a huge chip off a man and that's all
we've been a part of closer to me so
much so in fact don't you have a studio
in your basement I heard you have a
studio in your base I do actually I
enjoy making music just like a
basketball courts in a lot of these guys
homes I'm making music so I go to studio
and minds and spend fun they're so much
fun well I can't wait for the mixtape
are you ready to move on here
[Music]
we all know that one so yesterday you
went to your YouTube community tab and
you asked for questions for your hot
ones appearance so this one is all about
the fans the first ones from at bogar
what's been the best thing so far about
your offseason oh the best thing just
knowing that you a champion
know what it takes to get there so just
try to follow that same blueprint here
in the Europe if you could play with any
NBA player in history who would it be
and why
it'd probably have to be will
Chamberlain Argyll Magic Johnson tween
into the law yeah magic we was next
level so yeah I'm a huge fan all right
so this next one is from Kevin Julius
who is your celebrity crush growing up
and who is it now yeah yet a lot of them
yeah a big list yeah
Beyonce was really a Beyonce was during
your formative years or when I was a
teenager now no not now
but now I don't even know bro
to be honest I might want to take
advantage of the platform you know what
I mean yeah but let me look at my phone
or something first yeah I got so many
that I love but it's it's all I'm just
putting on too much under spotlight man
I have too much pressure on me right now
and I'm pissed that I can't get this
take advantage of that's on you it's a
blown opportunity KD one more for you
hey KD when you won the championship who
is the first person you called oh my god
father yeah call him back he's back on
Maryland you taught me how to play the
game does that must've been a big moment
for him oh yeah for sure we talked about
this for a long time
so like many players in the NBA know
that you're a 2k obsessive yeah when you
play other players in the league
who's your most formidable opponent is
your fiercest rival I played against
Kyrie a couple years ago an Olympics
head Xbox setup and he's pretty good
besides 2k what game do you play the
most Oh Rory McIlroy PGA Tour they play
that like seven eight hours a day
sometimes isn't maybe my friends going
on and play so much fun and then Gordon
Hayward once suggested that by playing
two K he became a better basketball
player in real life do you think that
there's something to that or is that
just crazy talk no it's a real thing
that's a real thing the game is so real
now
it's like watching film almost you know
they have so many different modes on
there as well they have a GM mode that I
played non-stop and I really feel like
the general manager the game is so real
now it makes it seem like you're
actually really get better but you're
probably not some of these balls not
even seen before all new field yeah I
know that you have to pocket a tune on
your leg Jesus on your back but at first
we feast the tattoo that were most
interested in is Rick James can you talk
about the decision to get Rick James
permanently inked on your body oh yeah
Rick James bearing back to a time where
like I first started listening that type
of music I remember I was right like
eight years old and I heard fire and
desire with Tina Marie and it just gave
me a different feeling in life you know
I want to recreate that feeling and I
spontaneously just got to touch him I
thought and I think I'm really excited
about it once I get older show my kids
Rick James on my dad you're gonna really
think I'm a cool dad so it's it's light
years that's what I think it's the light
years thing you got you can't in the
time you have to be looking around the
corner you can't know what I'm doing or
less you know I had to explain it to you
for you to get it
[Music]
so how you guys know you got your own
sauce not the only one out here not the
only one out here Kady what can you want
so we have a recurring segment on our
show called explain that Graham where we
do a deep dive in our guest Instagram I
know that you're a little new to the eat
I'll be back oh yeah you're making your
return to your hive so what we've done
is instead pulled some great throw backs
so I'll show you the picture and then
you tell me the bigger story what's
going on okay first one this looks like
a good time whew I was twenty-fifth
birthday but he just dropped nothing was
the same follows Lily it was so much fun
what do you remember about that night
nothing it's like you know you had a
good time from one base or its icon to
another talk to me about your
relationship with Andre Ward when I was
in OKC yes he signed with Roc Nation as
well so we we both kind of knew same
people and I asked him before some
assigned gloves cuz he's my favorite
boxer and I didn't know him at the time
and then when I moved to the bay we just
got tight and came out to support him
they're so happy that he won man he's a
real real good friend of Mines and our
relationship was growing and then I have
one more for you Katie I don't know if
this is the first time that you met Kobe
Bryant maybe it is maybe it isn't but
this is from 2007 from the USA team was
this the first time you met Kobe yeah
that was the first time I don't remember
the conversation but I can remember that
I was very very my I was shaking Kobe is
a god to me
basketball wise so just to see him
actually know my name at that time I was
18 it was a surreal if you learn
anything from him oh yeah when he did
every time you touch the ball shoot
[Music]
so now we're moving on to dirty dicks
very aggressive brain oh yeah
pause that how many shows you do a week
so your stomach can't be holding up I'm
trying you know
as an athlete you push it to the limit
right sometimes as a talk show host you
have to do the same thing especially
when you're just doing these interviews
over chicken wings all the time
everybody always wants to talk about the
MBA is being so cutthroat but I'm more
into the camaraderie of this situation
so what I want to do is hit you with
some things and you can tell me who in
the NBA you'd go for for advice about
that thing if you needed a good wine
recommendation could you go to for a
good wine recommendation
LeBron Braun knows his mine what about
for a stock tip I'm pretty good that
stuff only nobody care what if you need
a little veteran advice from someone
who's been in the league longer than you
who do you go to Nick House he's for a
guest verse would it be Damian Lillard
yeah yeah it would be day yeah he's a
best rapper in the league for style tips
one person I wouldn't go to his
trademark so know how bad I'll tell you
first
yeah Westbrook easily that's a crazy
name they don't try to pretend there's
something that they're not
oh no I want to I want to see if people
actually buy this stuff man for pranks
mm-hmm it's a dorm room prank that's a
do this on my wall is the only therefore
coming
[Music]
I've been a little watery up here be
careful around your eyes oh yeah so
nobody told me I can um yeah that's
pretty bad through touch your face with
this hmm
it's not happy going to know a veteran
move veteran movie so when it comes to
professional athlete Twitter fingers
yours are some of the most prolific what
are the things online the shenanigans
online that you find hardest to brush
off even though you know whatever you
respond millions of eyeballs are gonna
see it I just hate that basketball it
takes about my game you know that's what
gets me the most okay you told me I
can't shoot or I can't post up or I
can't pass I can't rebound we long to
fin will or I got yeah you'd say that
I go off your mentions right now Phil
enough yeah not go off but I'll
definitely try to make me feel stupid
I get the snake on this so many times
I'm like it's 10 to 100 is Omar that's
the next name spin it and then this
conversation it's actually a rather
poetic segue to the next wing how you
doing Kevin I'm sweating a little bit
over here I love I guess
so this one is the bomb beyond insanity
[Music]
Oh Ellie you taste like anything that's
just later was you bar even make that I
think just to help me with my YouTube
clout I know it was harvested in the
walls of hell but I got a lot of mileage
out of it
we got two more I know that you're not
shy about your criticisms of the media
via ESPN's bummy new segment or what
have you and I wonder you know what did
the ESPN's of the world the Bleacher
Report's of the world get wrong about
Katie well first of all down let me
create my own content and then let me
tell my own story so how can they tell
my story what I've been talking about -
that's why I'm on YouTube I get to tell
my own story and it's told by me the
person actually won't do it it's hard
for me to kind of respect someone
criticizing if you've never even been on
the stage before so that's why I go off
let me ask you this if you find yourself
in retirement on the other side of the
microphone what would you do differently
as a member of the sports press well I'm
gonna be all about the players and be
all about the players all about what
they want to do their product with a
product we're pushing the league the
players are pushing the league so so
always be about the players
I'm sorry I'm loaded nowadays it's like
a few between the players and the meat
is always like us versus them if there's
a conflict yeah it should just
appreciate what you see Madison this
beautiful art form is different from we
all creators to as basketball players
it's just different
appreciate that stop trying to compare
all the time alright so this one's
Blair's Megadeth sauce with liquid rage
it used to be our hottest sauce it's not
a second auto sauce next to just wash
ground
[Music]
oh no find it Kevin find it kevin here
from yes what is that it's a tough one
it's the liquid rage I think that's cool
here we go Kevin here we go Kevin so no
matter where you go and your MBA career
know that you're still a DC guy at heart
yeah which is more DC in your opinion
mumbo sauce or half smokes Oh
top-1 mumbo sauce is perhaps modes know
we used to cut the Harris with it yeah
yeah I'm gonna go mumbo sauce there but
it's a tough decision
oh yeah for sure excluding yourself
who's the best basketball player ever to
come out of the DMV the car Smith you
know yes
I can't plan ahead be able to use the
path how do I not even mean I'm not
paying he's more of a legend in DC
tonight
street ball scene see you that's why I
start playing street ball that's how I
know basketball through street ball so
and then sometimes that's where you
shine when it's the Truvia Kurtz Rucker
or poor very farms a lot that's where I
grew up so I London and Perry ball
anything I start watching NBA later so I
really started loving stars until I got
like teenage years so before then it was
a street ball in is that dinner for me
and Kurt Smith who I name was depressing
how do you explain go-go music to people
who don't know what it is I tried to
explain that to somebody the other day
and I was like I look so stupid
explaining it because it's like it's
such a unique sound I don't even know
how to just duplicate that like VBox
that you know so but everybody knows
what it is it just has a hidden
mainstream but it's it's deep in our
culture
tabby Bonet or wale both tough to pick
that's when I say when I get behind a
mic and we'll change it up so I'm Little
Bo ain't no comparing they both they
both showing the city love so I both
love
i'ma go I'm gonna go pull and then
what's your favorite Monument see I grew
up in Berlin and I never really went to
it in DC I'll never live into the
monuments I've never visited don't seem
like miles and miles away so I've never
been I just don't know what now I'm
thinking about so much at one time right
now well I'll only give you one more
sauce to think about I can't think right
now
this is the last dab it's a tough one
and we call it the last day of because
it's tradition around here to put a
little dab on the last wing you don't
have to if you don't want to Kevin
Durant but I think it's a good time to
mention that Kevin Love did
a little crazy Katy kitty going in going
in oh let me scoop some let me switch to
the other I got this mom
hi Katy
cheers Cheers
finding my mam sweating like you're at
the free-throw line I love it
[Music]
seriously like we didn't make this for
the show I would mix my way than that
that's the whole thing we don't want to
make a dorm prank sauce Kady we wanted
to make something that people would
actually like yeah well I want to make
my forehead time no cook can't have more
than four to it oh hi Katie you're a man
who has climbed many mountains in recent
years an MVP award a Finals MVP an NBA
champion and let the record show you
just crushed ten wings on hot ones
nothing to sneeze at so here we're
taking it back to the YouTube fans for
this one last question because at mze
leaky Ted needs to know what would you
tell someone who has big dreams and
goals but they're constantly told by
others that they're not gonna be and
I'll censor him ish well get from around
those people you need that you hang
around new people cuz they'll drink
their dragon bow easily no matter what
and just believe in yourself man but you
can't have belief without hard work so
you can say you want this I want that if
you cannot get enough of going to work
for every day you just talking to stuff
hopefully that helps it is great life
advice it's a pro tip from Kevin Durant
and what an amazing performance it feels
like Game five all over again when I
look across the table
we shall see this
[Music]
somebody closes yours if you ever had
the courage to go through the dog oh
yeah I would recommend all my friends to
come on this show he'll stop oh hello
world Sean Evans coming at you to say
thank you for watching if you like what
you saw please subscribe
we're hovering around the three
thousandth ranked youtube channel in the
world it has been a childhood dream of
mine to be somewhere in the mid twos
we're so close
help make an adult bald man's dreams
come true please please please jk jk no
pressure but if you do subscribe I
appreciate it